ladies and gentlemen Wee Man
yeah I did I love it so much when
somebody who I did a podcast with on
Zoom can then oh finally comes back in I
guess my first time in the van right we
were trying to do it in person and the
pandemic had just become a thing yeah
and you were like I'm living with
somebody who's immunocompromised and
it's just not responsible yeah my ex
she's like type 1 diabetic so dude I was
camping so much and barbecuing all the
time I was a grill mastering I cooked
for me they're like wood in a fire pit
to propane on a griddle Grill I learned
how to smoke Meats I think a lot of
people learned something new during that
time and that was mine I learned how to
talk over people on a podcast
you were already doing it way before
podcasts